nicht so hochwertige masken aus china um
dem bundesgesundheitsminister und seinem
ministerium und auch noch das
arbeitsministerium
das dauert noch ein bisschen wir sind
noch nicht dort angekommen aber mein
kollege und reporter im bundestag der
drachen von verlor übernimmt an dieser
stelle ja vielen dank ihr läuft noch die
fragestunde im deutschen bundestag und
ich kann ihnen noch mal sagen was uns
gleich in wenigen minuten erwartet war
der aktuellen stunde auf verlangen der
linksfraktion die haltestelle stunde
heißt presseberichte über vermeintlich
minderwertige masten für benachteiligte
menschen und erneuten masken skandal um
gesundheitsminister jens spahn nun fakt
ist dass es im herbst vergangenen jahres
zwischen dem bundesarbeitsministerium
und dem bundesgesundheitsministerium
gespräche gehabt wie man zb mit arbeit
mit wohnungslosen umgehen soll ob es da
nicht masken geben soll und
hartz-iv-empfängern und dann trennen
sich die berichte von beiden seiten
bemerkenswert ja dass man in einer
regierung gemeinsam sitzt aber einen
sachverhalt unterschiedlich darstellt
das ist ein veritabler streit der wäre
es nicht so kurz vor ende der
legislaturperiode sicherlich ganz andere
auswirkungen haben könnte jedenfalls
bleibt bislang unklar ob die masken die
angedacht waren dem europäischen
standard nicht nur entsprochen haben
sondern ihnen fehlte jegliche
schutzwirkung
das sagt das arbeitsministerium das
gesundheitsministerium sagt das stimmt
nicht es ist insofern etwas müßig als
dass diese masken gar nicht ausgeliefert
wurden zumindest in der menge nicht
sondern am schluss in anführungsstrichen
normale ffp zwei masken ausgeliefert
worden ein schwieriger sachverhalt der
jetzt in der vorwahlzeit zu einer
heftigen auseinandersetzung geführt hat
nicht nur zwischen der opposition und
der cdu in dem fall dem
gesundheitsministerium sondern auch
zwischen cdu und spd die die
bundeskanzlerin fühlte sich genötigt
sich vor ihren gesundheitsminister zu
stellen und die spd vorsitzenden beide
haben den rücktritt
von ihren sparen bei anklagt klar dass
die linksfraktionen die chance genutzt
hat diesen punkt heute noch mal
diskutieren zu lassen aber sehr gut
vielleicht kommt dann ein bisschen
klärung in diese maßnahme und jetzt geht
es also gleich los mit der aktuellen
stunde petra pau auf den punkt schon auf
um gesundheitsminister jens spahn
ich öffne die aussprache das wort hat
der kollege jan korte für die fraktion
die linke die antwort ist der
parlamentarische geschäftsführer hat als
erster das wort in die linke hat diese
aktuelle stunde beantragt
frau präsidentin meine damen und herren
worum geht es laut spiegel wurden
millionen mangelhafter masken in china
für viel geld vom gesundheitsminister
sparen eingekauft und sie sollten so die
berichterstattung an wohnungslose
behinderteneinrichtungen und hartz4
empfänger weitergegeben werden sollte
diese berichte zu stimmen ist der
vorgang an politischer und menschlicher
verkommenheit nicht mehr zu überbieten
und das ihren aller klassen das wollen
wir mal sehen ich finde es gut dass die
spd kurz vor den bundestagswahlen das
ganze mit ihrer pr abteilung unterstützt
das etwas spät aber immerhin eine späte
erkenntnis jetzt wollen wir kollege
ziehen merck darüber sprechen ob es
stimmt oder nicht
mir liegt ein schreiben des
sozialministeriums baden württemberg von
5 22 01 21 vor
wo auf die mangelhaftigkeit der
eingekauften masken aufmerksam gemacht
wird und wo eigene untersuchungen und
prüfungen durch die dekra veranlasst
wurde ich möchte jetzt aus diesem zitat
und im ergebnis der prüfung zitieren
damit wir uns der wahrheit näher kollege
team merke ich zitiere die ergebnisse
liegen nun weitestgehend vor und haben
ergeben dass von 27 getesteten masken
des lagerbestandes aus der bund und
landes beschaffung 13 nicht den
anforderungen nach euro-norm 149 genügen
zitat endet ist das ergebnis der dekra
untersuchung die meisten mängel sind
übrigens dahingehen festgestellt worden
was die durchlässigkeit der masken
angeht wer sagt hier kollege ziemlich
eigentlich die wahrheit das wollen wir
überlegen ich tippe jens spahn tut es
nicht warum komme ich zu dieser aussage
und zu dieser einschätzung ich möchte
versuchen es zu begründen
dafür gehen wir endlich zurück in die
zeit des beginns der pandemie und zwar
in den zwanzigster oktober 2020 der ein
oder andere wird sich noch erinnern dass
dort ein tag vor erklärt wurde dass die
leute bei den ihren wohnungen bleiben
sollten und sich nicht mehr mit anderen
leuten treffen sollten und schon gar
keine partys feiern soll wenn sich der
ein oder andere daran erinnert vor allem
aus der union
und gleichzeitig wird ein tag später der
bundesgesundheitsminister zu einer
spenden party nach leipzig wo also sehr
viele illustre gäste die wir alle bis
heute nicht kennen übrigens auch das ist
eine frage zufällig 9.999 euro an den
kreisverband des gesundheitsministers
gespendet haben also genau ein euro
unter der veröffentlichungspflicht wir
ihnen das mal sagen was das problem ist
ja warum das was damit zu tun hat
wenn ich in meinem fall etwas das ich in
bitterfeld köthen oder bernburg martina
party dazu ein bier gehe da kriege ich
maximal ein pilz 03 ausgegeben aber da
hängen keine leute rum die fast 10.000
euro miete stecken dass der unterschied
und deswegen und deswegen sollte man mal
überlegen mit wem man eigentlich so
rumhängt und das färbt nämlich
irgendwann auch ab wenn man nur noch mit
dem geldadel rumhängen und nicht mehr
mitbekommt was an der basis dieser
gesellschaft stattfindet zweiter punkt
märz 2021 ja ich weiß dass sie das nicht
gerne hören wollen die berühmte masken
affäre der cdu csu ist ja so als ob er
nie irgendwas geschehen ist würde ich ja
nicht nur nur eine person der kollege
nüßlein war es glaube ich 600.000 euro
in die eigene tasche gesteckt hat auch
das ist noch nicht aufgeklärt inwieweit
eigentlich ihr haus davon wusste und
irgendwie involviert gewesen ist kommen
wir in die aktuelle zeit um den reigen
komplett zu machen kommen wir in den mai
2021 das ging ja breit durch die medien
und jeder der irgendwie nicht völlig
blind und nicht sehend hier durch das
land geht konnte das ja sehen bei den
testzentren dass sie also
den roten teppich ausgelegt haben
irgendwelche dubiosen leute also ein
teil kuriose leute die unfassbar viel
geld mit testzentren gemacht werden und
anstatt dafür verantwortung zu
übernehmen
zu handeln fällt ihnen nichts anderes
ein als die aufsichtspflicht an die
kommunen abzuschieben die wegen der
pandemie unterfonds auftritt aus dem
letzten loch pfeifen verantwortung haben
sie nicht einmal übernommen das
skandalöse um das auch hier zu binden
leider reichen fünf minuten überhaupt
nicht dafür bräuchte man zwei stunden
hier zu diskutieren um diese ganzen
fehlverhalten und das versagen hier
minuziös auszusagen
ich möchte trotzdem noch mal ein paar
sachen in erinnerung rufen also in allem
ziemlich gut herr minister nämlich das
ist im ankündigen und danach werden die
ankündigungen entweder von der
bundeskanzlerin was macht die eigentlich
die scheint er dem erdkreis auch völlig
entrückt zu sein mittlerweile keine
ahnung was sie eigentlich in diesem
ganzen affären tut sie kündigen an und
danach kann es nicht eingehalten werden
immer wieder und immer wieder immer
wieder das geht immer so weiter vor
allem ganz aktuell auch das kann ich
belegen kollegen jack weil sie immer
mehr auf den boden schauen die zuletzt
genannte aufhebung der priorisierung man
muss sich das einmal reinziehen und die
hinzunahme auch von jüngeren menschen in
die impfkampagne
das verkünden sie mit riesen tamtam also
immerhin ihre social media kanäle das
funktioniert ja nicht schlecht aber das
verkünden sie einfach und mensch siehe
da die leute stehen da und es gibt gar
keinen weiteren impfstoff was ist das
denn für eine politik so verspielt man
die akzeptanz der leute beim kampf gegen
die pandemie letzter punkt ihres
politischen versagen zu die auch noch
mal sagen anstatt sich in der patents
tag an die seite der linken und des us
präsidenten so bogen zu stellen und für
die aufhebung der patente zu kämpfen
sind sieht der schutzschirm der
pharmalobbyisten das ist das traurig und
ich finde ihn einst sein wenn das virus
in
art und weise im globalen süden so
mutiert das mädchen nicht mehr in den
griff bekommen dann tragen sie aufgrund
dieser politik dafür mit die persönliche
verantwortung um das auch hier ganz
deutlich einmal anzusprechen
deswegen kann ich nur zusammenfassende
fragen über ihre tätigkeit hier
dargelegt warum sollte man ihnen glauben
das einzige was bei ihnen und übrigens
auch bei ihrem kumpel an die steuer
wirklich wirklich beeindruckend das ist
wie man eine so schlechte politik so
viele skandale und so viele milliarden
verbrennen kann und dass sie trotzdem
machen abend sind das ist wirklich eine
leistung da muss auch obmann
hinterziehen vielen dank
jan korte für die linke war dass sie als
gesehen der bundesgesundheitsminister
aber auch der bundesarbeitsminister sind
beide im raum liegt bereits die
rednerliste der kommenden stunde vor
bislang stehen beide nicht auf der liste
was ich als unangemessen empfinden wenn
es doch um diesen vorgang geht zwischen
diesen beiden häusern
wer ist doch schön wenn die beiden
häuser hier ihre chefs zumindest auch
mal zu wort kommen und sich äußern kann
mag jetzt die gesundheitspolitische
sprecherin der cdu
und deswegen zunächst einmal für den
rest ist es kleiner satz vielleicht das
wichtigste
jedenfalls die meisten von uns meinen
dass selbstverständlich die
einrichtungen und die obdachlosen und
behindert der obdachlosen und
behindertenhilfe gute und sichere masken
ausdrücklich aus deutscher produktion
erhalten haben
diese genauso wichtig ist uns jetzt in
der union aber auch dass die masken die
ursprünglich für die belieferung
vorgesehen waren die sogenannten cp
geprüften masken diesen zweck genauso
gut und vollumfänglich erfüllt hätten
was heißt denn nun cpi sie wissen oder
zumindest die gesundheitspolitiker hier
müssen das ce zertifiziert und damit in
europa verkehrs fähige masken zu beginn
der pandemie nicht verfügbar
deshalb hat die kommission ihren
mitgliedsstaaten einfachere verfahren
zur einführung und nutzung von
persönlicher schutzausrüstung zb aus
china ermöglicht das bmg hat dann
gemeinsam mit dem b fahren
dem bundesinstitut für arzneimittel und
medizinprodukte und weiteren
institutionen renommierten institutionen
dazu gehört auch herr kollege konnte die
dekra
der typ hat einen besonderen prüf
maßstab entwickelt geben um gesundheits
und sicherheits anfang und trotzdem
jederzeit gewährleisten zu können und
der brut maßstab ist wissenschaftlich
abgesichert und hat mittlerweile unter
dem begriff cpi das in die korona
pandemie infektionsschutz maßnahmen
eingang in das infektionsschutzgesetz
und dort um die anlage zu § 5b gefunden
das bms wiederum verwendet für seinen
bereich den arbeitsschutz ebenfalls
einen vereinfachten prüf grundsatz ca
und da steht das kürzel für corona
pandemie atemschutzmasken
beide verfahren sind soweit den
infektionsschutz bereich betrifft
deckungsgleich und bei den cpi geprüften
masken wird im vergleich zu den ca
masken lediglich auf die temperatur
konditionierung ein und eine verlängerte
anrege prüfung als ski maske passt
verzichtet beides wichtige aspekte für
den arbeitsschutz wird aber nicht für
die schutzwirkung gegen das co2 virus
das in diese beiden aspekte nicht
relevant und solche cpi masken sind in
der pandemie übrigens vom bund und von
allen gesundheitsministern der länder
millionenfach eingesetzt worden und
können zum infektionsschutz auch
weiterhin eingesetzt werden über diese
tauglichkeit zum infektionsschutz
besteht überdies einvernehmen in der
gesamten bundesregierung einschließlich
heil auch mit dem thema essen genau
deswegen wurden beide prüfverfahren cph
und cpi auch als voraussetzung dafür
genommen dass die masken in die
nationale reserve aufgenommen werden
können um was geht's also politik die
nutzung unterschiedlicher prüfverfahren
infektions die arbeitsschutz ist seit
sechs monaten geklärt
und letzte woche kurz vor der
landtagswahl in sachsen anhalt wird
daraus an ein an den haaren
herbeigezogene vorwurf konstruiert der
skandal sind nicht die masse sondern das
handeln der akteure vor allem aus dem
wilbrand aus und von minister hahn
noch nicht einmal die opposition nun
geprüft solche ehrabschneidende
persönlich sehr verletzende
formulierungen und anhörung wie eben das
leitungspersonal unseres
koalitionspartners
jetzt kann ich verstehen dass man einen
dauernden umfragen und wahlergebnissen
wie es jüngst in sachsen anhalt mit acht
prozent erreicht wurde
in erklärungsnot kommt es ist für mich
vielleicht sogar noch nachvollziehbar
wenn die parteivorsitzende deshalb zu
jedem sich bietenden ablenkungsmanöver
greifen um von der eigenen ratlosigkeit
abzulenken
aber da sie nun bewusst besonders
honorare gruppen die obdachlos die
menschen mit behinderung verunsichern
nur um parteipolitische stimmung zu
machen
das ist
[Applaus]
es lag ja nun kein minister für sie eine
gute ausgangsbasis für die wahl als
aktions vorsitzender in der nächsten
legislaturperiode sein wenn sie sich mit
solchen falschen vorwürfen zu wort
melden und die sich dann bei der
überprüfung in luft auslösen
aber sie haben noch immer nicht
begriffen dass wir als teil der rea der
regierung die regierung mit track
bewirbt sich auch selbst beschmutzt es
sind noch wenige monate die wir zusammen
arbeiten müssen
ich erwarte dass ist sich gemeinsam mit
uns um die probleme der menschen kümmern
lassen sie uns arbeit seien sie
behindert oder stören sie wenigstens
nicht einbringen sehr dankbar
clark war dass die sicherheitspolitische
sprecherin der cdu csu fraktion
der nächste redner kommt von der afd
stefan reuter ich je weiter er ist
mitglied im finanzausschuss der afd
[Applaus]
frau präsidentin meine sehr geehrten
damen und herren die letzten jahre haben
wir vor den linken nicht viel
vernünftiges gehört an dieser stelle
möchte ich mich bei ihnen ausdruck
vorsommer hören sie mal zu ich wollte
mich gerade ausdrücklich bei ihnen
bedanken dass sie dieses thema auf die
tagesordnung gebracht haben weil es ist
extrem wichtig dass masken thema
beschäftigte und schon länger und wir
haben eine ganze menge anfragen
diesbezüglich an die regierung gestellt
aus dem hause fahren kam dann nicht viel
sehr viel heiße luft die
parlamentarischen anfragen wurden
meistens durch die staatssekretärin weiß
abgetan
wir haben hier keine antworten der
bundesregierung erhalten wenn man etwas
mehr über diesen ganzen masken skandal
erfahren möchte muss man recherchieren
und meine fraktion hat recherchiert wie
haben lieferanten kontaktiert wir haben
zuträger gehabt wir haben zum träger
passen sie auch aus der bundesregierung
gab von ihrem rechtsberater ernst &
young und hier sind unterlagen
rausgekommen die schwer belasten und
schwer beschämend für diese
bundesregierung sind wenn ich mir das
angucken wie die masken beschafft worden
sind
vor einem jahr märz april letzten jahres
da sind verträge geschlossen wurden mit
unternehmen wie lufthansa basf otz da
die verträge liegen hier vor
das sind 16 seitigen verträge die
relativ ordentlich geschlossen sind bei
dieser recherche sind aber auch andere
verträge aufgetaucht unter anderem
verträge mit einer fliege logistik
stiftung & co kg die dann übertragen
worden sind auf eine fähige
international beteiligungs gmbh eine
glitschige gmbh kurz spd abgekürzt die
vor vertragsschluss 40 millionen euro
aufs konto
bekommen hat das ein skandal
sondergleichen ersparen diese verträge
sind geschlossen worden wenn ich mir das
hier mal angucken das sind zwei blätter
papier
die stehen für fast eine oder über eine
halbe milliarde euro beschaffungsvolumen
wohin welt wildwestmanier verträge
geschlossen worden sind wo noch nicht
mal ein stempel vorhanden war da es an
schriftlich fit gmbh ergänzt worden das
ist unwürdig und hier sind betrug tür
und tor geöffnet
ich frage mich warum ist die fbb gmbh
oder fieber überhaupt aus gewählt worden
ersparen hängt es damit zu tun dass hier
persönliche bekanntschaften bestehen
dass das im nachbarwahlkreis ist die
fiege logistik hat überhaupt gar keine
expertise ebendieser logistik die hier
gefordert wird hat keine eigene
flugzeuge wo es darum ging
schutzausrüstung einzufliegen einen
rahmenvertrag der 31
2020 beschlossen wurde ist übertragen
wurden auch die fbs es dann drei tage
später am 24
2020 noch mal einen preis nachschlag von
10 cent vereinbart worden bei gesprächen
mit lieferanten ist mir versichert
worden dass es üblich ist wenn noch ein
zwischenhändler mitverdienen will das
passiert immer in zehn cent schritten
da frage ich mich wer hat hier dran noch
mal mit verdient das volumen allein in
dieses vertrages dieses rahmenvertrages
liegt bei 545 millionen euro
die konditionen sind ein traum
erfüllungsort shanghai keine
frachtkosten bei musste keine
verzögerung machen man muss sich nicht
um zertifikate kümmert wie die ware ins
land kommt vereinbart waren ffp zwei
masken soweit ich weiß war nur ein ganz
geringer bruchteil tatsächlich ffp zwei
mussten die eingeflogen worden sind dann
durch die bundesregierung man ist dem
problem entgangen indem man selber als
in verkehr bringen aufgetaucht ist
lieferanten bestätigten mir dass der
markt im märz april letzten jahres
maximal zwei euro für sap zwei masten
verzollt iq sie fracht und
einfuhrumsatzsteuer vergab diese masten
die die bundesregierung beschafft und in
verkehr gebracht haben waren mangelhaft
grob mangelhaft insbesondere
mängel wurden bei diesem schnitt es ein
partikel durchlass zulässig waren sechs
prozent die masken wiesen in der regel
um die 15 prozent auf außerdem taucht
immer wieder ein name auch eine kleine
bruder aus der schweiz im mix mit der
die bundesregierung milliarden verträge
geschlossen hat hier möchte ich auch
gerne einmal hinter die kulissen schauen
und gucken was hier tatsächlich passiert
ist
im gegenzug hat die bundesregierung ein
open house verfahren ausgeschrieben 100
lieferanten sind heute immer noch
bezahlt eine milliarde euro ist hier
noch strittig man hat wieder mal sich
seines partners michael bedienen um
diese forderung abzuwehren
hier stehen existenzen vom kleinen
lieferanten auf dem spiel die alles
verwendet haben um der bundesregierung
aus einer krise zu helfen
schutzausrüstung zu schaffen
juristische winkelzüge ziehen sich jetzt
auch ein fix geschäft zurück ich sage
mit den unterlagen die aus ihrem hause
gekommen sind lässt sich dieses fix
geschäft kippen
außerdem viel laufen diese
beschaffungskette das tauchen immer
wieder nahm auch monika hohlmeier
strauß-tochter januar die amigo affäre
man kennt sich man hilft sich das ist
offensichtlich hängen geblieben
mir sind protokolle vorgelegt werden
frau hohlmeier empfiehlt anime zöllner
die wiederum gute kontakte zum
bundesministerium so kürzt man
beschaffungsprozesse ab ich sage ihnen
der fisch zum teil ausgenommen wurden
die cdu hat sich bereits von einigen
abgeordneten getrennt die sich
persönlich bereichert haben oder wo der
verdacht im raum steht der fisch stinkt
aber immer vom kopf und hier ist doch
viel zu viel verwesungsgeruch in diesem
hause
wir haben hier in ein wespennest
gestoßen
ich komme zum ende frau präsidentin ich
sage ihnen wir werden diese sache noch
aufarbeiten müssen das schreit nach
einem untersuchungsausschuss leider erst
nach der bundestagswahl
ich bin sicher das ist nicht nur ein
fall für ein untersuchungsausschuss
sondern auch noch für den staatsanwalt
unser vorsitzender sagte wir werden sie
jetzt bitte zu mischen uns herr
bundesminister sie wissen jetzt was
jahren bedeutet vielen dank so und jetzt
kommt mit katja mast der
stellvertretende fraktionsvorsitzende
der spd die erste spd rednerin vor ort
und ich darf nur daran erinnern dass die
cdu/csu noch gemeinsam mit der spd in
einer bundesregierung dieses land
[Applaus]
ich will ihnen einmal sagen dass ihre
ausführungen zu den qualitätsfragen in
vielerlei hinsicht fehlerhaft waren
meine kollegin martina stamm fiebig wird
es in ihrer rede klar stellen
aber eins lasse ich mir von ihnen nicht
gefallen der vorwurf dass hier seine
parteipolitische debatte sie glauben es
nötig sein generalsekretär sprechen zu
lassen nicht wir
was will ich nur einmal an dieser stelle
sagen es geht in richtung politik es
geht hier auch nicht um eine
personalfrage
es geht hier einzigen es geht hier
einzig und allein darum dass wir in der
pandemie alle menschen im land im
gleichen maße schützen daran geht es
hier
deshalb hat sich die spd
bundestagsfraktion und die spd dafür
eingesetzt dass menschen mit behinderung
wohnungslose und
grundsicherungsempfänger fsg zwei
schutzmasken erhalten ist doch
eigentlich auch logisch und einfach nur
anständig schutzmasken haben in diesem
land qualitätsstandards im märz 2020 hat
sich die bundesregierung auf standards
geeinigt für masken aus china und darum
geht es gilt eine verkürzte prüfung nach
ca
verfahren und es wird kein unterschied
zwischen infektionsschutz und
arbeitsschutz masken gemacht und dieser
cbr standard ist der mini boom egal in
welchem bereich diese masken eingesetzt
werden
sie müssen wirksam schützen durch die
berichterstattung im spiegel stellt
jetzt fragen den baum wurde zu jedem
zeitpunkt die schutz und
sicherheitsstandards der bundesregierung
durch das haus von jens spahn
gewährleistet gab es versuche die
vereinbarten sicherheits und prüfstand
ups zu unterlaufen lief ihr alles sauber
wurde versucht nach diesen standards
nicht getestete masken an menschen mit
behinderung wohnungslose und
grundsicherungsempfänger zu verteilen
und ganz konkret drei mal soll das
gesundheitsministerium den versuch
unternommen haben
die vereinbarten qualitätsstandards
gegenüber dem sozialministerium
abzusenken
das sozialministerium hat das verhindert
nicht das gesundheitsministerium die
leidtragenden wären besonders
schutzbedürftige gewesen dass meine
damen und herren wäre mehr als eine
unverschämtheit
es wäre zynisch und völlig inakzeptabel
denn zu dem zeitpunkt machen genügen ft2
schutzmasken am markt vorhanden das
sozialministerium wurde dann wurden dann
sicher geprüfte masken geliefert was
mich wahnsinnig ärgert ist der ulmer
hrige vorwurf die spd und hubertus heil
diese debatte forciert oder gar bestellt
nichts
nichts davon ist wahr was aber wo ist
und ihr schreien bestätigt ja dass ich
recht habe
was aber war es das ipad es rein und
sein haus jederzeit jederzeit das
gesundheitsministerium darauf aufmerksam
gemacht haben das singen des standards
nicht mitgetragen werden
klare ansage dpa getestete machst und
kommen nicht cp atteste masken kommen
nicht in den umlauf
auch wenn sie jetzt in der notreserve
liegen im haus kommen sie nur
vollständig getestet hubertus heil das
sozialministerium sind die garanten für
das einhalten von sicherheitsstandards
die spd macht hier anständig ihren job
sie übernimmt verantwortung nun steht
die frage im raum warum sie ersparen
nach der devise angriff ist die beste
verteidigung agieren was wollen sie
damit erreichen wollen sie etwas
vertuschen
wieso haben sie nicht auf die
warnsignale aus den bundesländern
reagiert der brief aus baden württemberg
war schon im gespräch es gab
verteilungen durch lierhaus an
pflegeeinrichtungen die nicht den
standards entsprochen haben die die
länder selbst geprüft haben
souveräner umgang mit kritischen
hinweisen sieht anders aus alles angriff
ist nicht immer die beste verteidigung
demut und aufklärung sind angebracht
wo ist ihr bekenntnis wo ist ihr
bekenntnis sich jederzeit um die
einhaltung der vereinbarten
schutzstandards engagiert zu haben
ersparen haben sie da ihren job gemacht
diese fragen müssen sie beantworten und
nicht probiert es heil oder das
sozialministerium
soweit also kanzler mast für die spd sie
haben die beiden minister eben im kurzen
gespräch gesehen beide haben sich
persönlich sehr gut verstanden die
letzten jahre das dürfte wohl auch nicht
mehr der fall sein nämlich mal an man
sitzt gemeinsam in einer regierung
erläutert aber
hier die konflikte öffentlich zur
begeisterung der opposition wieland
schinnenburg kurzfristig die größte
herausforderung seit jahrzehnten für die
welt für deutschland und minister sparen
ist der ihn in dessen ressort das feld
jeder ich zumindestens hätte immer
verständnis dafür dass dort mal was
daneben geht gar keine frage aber meine
damen und herren auch in solchen krisen
gilt ein grundsatz ein minister muss
mindestens zwei dinge leisten
offenheit und selbstkritik minister
sparen betreute in medien zitiert mit
dem satz zitieren mit erlaubnis der
präsidentin da wo ich herkomme sagt man
entschuldigung zitat ende
gute idee herr minister dann fangen sie
doch mal selber damit an kunden sie
beschuldigen sich einmal für ihre vielen
fehler die es jetzt gemacht haben dass
nämlich die wichtigsten aufzählen die
konzentriere mich wesentlich auf die
frage der masken
erster punkt sie haben dieses land auf
diese pandemie nicht vorbereitet zu
beginn der pandemie gab es praktisch
keine schutzausrüstung in deutschland
und das obwohl seit 2013 bereits
krisenszenarien vorlagen die genau das
verlangen sie haben versagt bereits vor
der pandemie meine damen und herren
der zweite punkt sind die pandemie dann
dabei haben sie wochen lang gebraucht um
zu reagieren schließlich haben sie für
über sechs milliarden euro
schutzausrüstung eingekauft zu völlig
überteuerten preisen und in ganz vielen
fällen mit unzureichender qualität meine
damen und herren auch das geht nicht
dritter punkt anstatt das einzuräumen
und konsequenzen zu ziehen haben sie
einen neuen angriffe völlig
unzureichenden prüf standard für masken
erfunden oder finden lassen diesen cpi
prüfungsstandard dieses tatsächlich
unzureichend da geht es am wenigsten
darüber ob nur die temperatur test
gemacht wurde nicht es geht vor allem
darum dass zig millionen masken nur
stichprobenartig geprüft wurden aber
nicht die herstellungs einrichtung das
gehört bei medizinprodukten immer dazu
es werde nicht nur stichproben einzelne
produkte geprüft sondern werden auch die
fertigungsanlagen geprüft das konnten
sie nicht machen weil es in china sind
allein deshalb ist der tb ist schon
völlig unzureichend gewährleistet den
bürger
dieses landes keine sicherheit wird
obdachlosen noch anderen menschen man
gesamten so geht es nicht
der vierte punkt sie haben auch jetzt
ist nicht geschafft eine nationale
reserve gesundheitsschutz aufzubauen die
es in kinderschuhen bestens warten und
der hohen ist der folgende vor allem
haben sie bisher dort eingelagert genau
diese zb masken mit anderen worten also
denn die nächste pandemie kommenden
dürfen alle bürger mit ihren
unzureichenden mussten sich versorgen
das alleine schon ein skandal ist dass
in zumuten wollen wir den nächsten
pandemie mit ihren masken auskommen zu
müssen so jetzt nicht meine damen und
herren
5 sie haben ende 2020 für 2,5 milliarden
euro an besonders gefährdete personen
schutzmasken ich würde sagen verteilt
das haben sie gar nicht gemacht sie
haben gutscheine verschickt für 2,5
milliarden euro
da war 70 euro pro person es kann jetzt
70 euro pro person für ein paar
schutzmasken und das schlimmste daran
war diese personen hatten nicht etwa
schutzmasken zu hause sie mussten mit
diesen gutscheinen ungeimpft in die
gefährliche umgebung hin sind sie hier
schutzmasken dort abholen meine damen
und herren wendischen wir geld ausgeben
dann schicken sie läutet wenigstens zu
damit sich noch zusätzlich gefährden
müssen auch das ist ein skandal meine
damen und herren sie dort gemacht haben
sechstens geldverschwendung
steuergeldverschwendung ist ein
markenzeichen des ministers seit
amtsantritt hat der fast 200 stellen in
seinem ministerium zusätzlich geschafft
und zwar bereits vor der pandemie
doch das macht mich alles gefragt mach
doch mal ein anfang ich mache das gern
da fällt man viel
zweiter punkt sie haben über 500
millionen euro ausgegeben wird zuerst
die intensivbetten und parallel dazu ist
die zahl der verfügbaren intensivbetten
zurückgegangen das muss man auch erst
mal schaffen meine damen und herren und
der dritte punkt diese verschwendung von
geld bei den testzentren haben minister
scholz bekommt gleich herr minister
spanien haben sie mit zu verantworten
ist es richtig die länder müssen die
kontrollen machen aber die kontroll
grundsätze werden vom bund gemacht und
da haben sie versagt haben
eine ausreichend kontroll grundsätze
entwickelt sie wollen jetzt nachbessern
was zeigt dass am anfang unzureichend
war also auch die geldverschwendung bei
den test viertel haben sie mit zu
verantworten der minister sparen auch
das passt zu dem gesamtbild was sie hier
abgeben
siebter punkt sie haben auch mit zu
verantworten dass dieses land viel zu
wenig impfstoff bekommen hat ja die
verträge wurden von der eu beschlossen
aber wer war denn wer hat in die
ratspräsidentschaft im zweiten halbjahr
2020 gehabt deutschland und werte in
dieser zeit den vorsitz der eu minister
für gesundheit herr spahn
ersparen sie hätten eingreifen müssen
wenn die tester ist die eu falsche
verträge macht damit sind sie auch mit
führen durch dafür dass dieses land nach
wie vor viel zu wenig impfstoffe hat
viel weniger als manche andere länder
die bessere verträge geschlossen haben
meine damen und herren finden sich auch
ein paar fehler zu viel
die spd versucht er hier nun dort wo
nicht raus zu sorgen
meine damen und herren das reicht ihnen
nicht ich habe minister scholz vor drei
wochen hier gefragt was wir gegen die
geldverschwendung getan und antwort er
vertraut minister sparen
das ist eines finanzministers und würde
ich meine damen und herren
finanzminister hat auf die steuergeld zu
achten und nicht ein minister einfach
machen zu lassen
unsere förderung der freien demokraten
die minister sprachen sind drei erstens
entschuldigt sich hier und heute für
ihre fehler
zweitens gehen das sorgt für die mit
steuergeld und drittens denken sie
künftig ein bisschen länger nach bevor
die versprechung machen die sie nicht
halten können vielen dank meine damen
und herren
wieland schinnenburg für die fdp er hat
anders als die beiden spd vorsitzenden
nicht den rücktritt offiziell gefordert
des ministers jens spahn den wir hier
nochmal groß im bild sehen beide
beteiligten minister sind anwesend aber
beide stehen nicht auf der rednerliste
maria klein schmeink jetzt bündnis
90/die grünen stellvertretende
fraktionsvorsitzende
diesem thema zurückzukommen denn es sind
äußerst schwerwiegende vorwürfe in der
öffentlichen debatte wo es darum geht
das minderwertige oder zumindestens
unzureichend geprüfte schutzmasken
ausgegeben wurden sind am menschen die
in besonderer weise gefährdet sind durch
eine corona infektion menschen mit
behinderung menschen in wohnungslosen
einrichtung darum geht es und damit
verbunden meine damen und herren ist
auch eine ganz massive verunsicherung
wie stark und wie verlässlich kann ich
mich darauf verlassen dass in diesem
staat tatsächlich gesundheitsschutz ganz
ganz vorne steht und dass eben nicht das
kuppeln das verstecken von irgendwelchen
vorgängen vorrechnet ist darum genau
geht es und diese chance muss die
regierung hier an dieser stelle und zwar
beide fraktionen ergreifen
diesen verdacht auszuräumen denn er ist
zutiefst verstörend und wenn ich dann
mal schauen was haben sie hier
abgeliefert da würde ich mal sagen ja
szenen einer zerrütteten ehe das kann
man sagen
aber beide
hatten dafür dazu hier wirklich klarheit
herzustellen das haben sie nicht und das
muss man ganz klar einfordern und ich
muss auch sagen nachdem wir bereits im
letzten jahr eine kleine anfrage genau
zu diesen vorgängen gestellt haben wie
stark können wir uns auf die
qualitätsstandard dieser auf china
beschafften masten verlassen und in
diesem jahr im april erneut eine kleine
anfrage gestellt haben weil es aktuell
seit beginn dieses jahres vielfältige
hinweise auf mangelhafte masken aus
diesen beschaffen gegeben hat und wir
dabei keine ausreichenden antworten
abgehalten haben und da muss ich sagen
herr minister und aber auch minister hey
ich hätte schon erwarten dass sie diese
kleine anfrage nutzen um die notwendige
klarheit herzustellen
denn da drauf haben die bürgerinnen und
bürger einen wirklichen anspruch und da
muss man sagen sie bleiben viele
antworten schuldig aber als erstes
bleiben sie die antwort schuldig warum
sie seit dem es seit anfang des jahres
so viele hinweise gibt dass auf diesen
beschafften mengen tatsächlich
minderwertige masken und zwar vermehrt
aufgetaucht sind in baden württemberg im
rheinland pfalz in schleswig holstein
bei der probe mit zeit online veranlasst
hat mit stiftung warentest bei den
eigenständigen untersuchungen wieder die
der spiegel vorgenommen hat das muss
doch dann anlass sein tatsächlich zu
überprüfen was tue ich denn eigentlich
und wie können wir sicherstellen dass
diese maske nicht in den allgemeinen
verkehr und schon gar nicht in die 1
sturm kommen wo besonders gefährdete
menschen leben das wäre ihre aufgabe und
deshalb von unserer seite wir verlangt
maximale transparenz und sachliche
aufklärung es muss um sachliche
aufklärung gehen natürlich ist es so
gewesen dass wir letztes jahr froh waren
um jede maske die irgendwoher beschafft
werden konnten und natürlich haben wir
damals zurecht abstriche bei der
sicherheit gemacht weil es gegen darum
entweder habe ich eine maske oder ich
habe keine entweder ich hab nur eine
alltags masken oder mindestens einen
halben man standard das ist aber in
zeiten des mangels
außerdem sind wir längst weg und seit
mindestens ende letzten jahres hätten
das aufhören müssen und es hätte nicht
dazu kommen dürfen dass man
einrichtungen von menschen mit
behinderung pflegeheim und auch der
wohnungslosenhilfe diese mindestens
unzureichend geprüften masten der
versucht weiterzugeben das hätte nicht
passieren dürfen und es ist passiert und
dass es nachhaltig an ganz ganz vielen
stellen wieder zu sehen
zu sehen weshalb es ja diese rückrufe
gegeben hat deshalb schaffen sie
klarheit schaffen sie uns geben sie uns
akten einsicht in alle relevanten akten
die damit verbunden sind das ist das
eine insbesondere auch die prüfberichte
aus diesen test prüfungen die es gegeben
hat und marken prüfung und prüfen sie
die masken in der reserve nach damit
sichergestellt wird dass wir nicht eine
gesundheits reserve haben eine
tonal die letztendlich nur aus schrott
masten besteht das erwarten wir von ihm
und ich will das können die bürgerinnen
und bürger zu recht von ihnen verlangen
der minister gesundheitsschutz aber auch
herr minister mein heim
gesundheitsschutz ist in ihren beiden
ressorts zu den sehr prominenten
aufgaben lösen sie das ein
also die minister sitzen zwar immer noch
nebeneinander jetzt wortlos dafür hat
jetzt hier im parlament der erste
parlamentarische geschäftsführer der cdu
csu fraktion michael grosse
frau präsidentin liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen die bekämpfung der korona
pandemie ist erfolgreich das merken wir
jeden tag das zeigen auch alle zahlen
das zeigen die stattfinden lockerungen
und das zeigen nicht zuletzt die täglich
steigenden impfung ja manches schneller
manche sind auch besser laufen können
wir reden jetzt über einen vorgang ein
mega skandal der über ein jahr zurück
liegt kurz vor der landtagswahl
plötzlich aktuell wird dazu komme ich
noch insgesamt ist festzustellen diese
bundesregierung hat das land bisher gut
durch die pandemie geführt und das nicht
zuletzt das liegt nicht zuletzt an der
tatkräftigen und sehr guten arbeit des
bundesgesundheitsministers jens spahn
dafür sind wir sehr dankbar
und jetzt wo die wirklich nur zufällig
man weiß nicht wie so etwas passiert vor
der landtagswahl in sachsen anhalt das
macht alles wirklich zufall sein
ich weiß noch nicht ob das
arbeitsministerium daran beteiligt war
wie man lesen musste ich weiß das alles
nicht ich will das auch nicht behaupten
aber es wird ja ein bisschen versucht
aus einer sache die vor einem jahr
stattgefunden hat irgendwo jetzt einen
großen skandal zu konstruieren
dafür gab es extra große lautsprecher in
in form der beiden spd
parteivorsitzenden die dann sagten
menschen verachten menschenunwürdig
schallte es aus dem willy-brandt-haus
skandale um masken im ministerium
wir wissen heute alles heiße luft die
betroffene masken sind sogar mit
zustimmung der spd in die nationale
pandemie reserve aufgenommen worden
die spd-landesregierung bewerten die
masken als unbedenklich und haben sie
teilweise selbst gekauft der angebliche
der angebliche skandal das muss man
heute feststellen des
bundesgesundheitsministers ist längst
ein echter skandal dem willy brandt haus
geworden das ist weil sich
ein deutsches nachrichtenmagazin weil es
ja auch die fresse magazine betrifft die
in der aktuellen stunde ein deutsches
nachrichtenmagazin hat sich das schon
längst korrigiert
in den presseberichten liest man von
vorgehen unterste schublade
oder man schreibt man hätte mit dreck
geworfen nach dem motto irgendwas bleibt
schon hängen ich sage an dieser stelle
fragen wo sind sie eigentlich schade
nicht da treues kind walter borjans
zeigen zurück sagt rückgrat und
entschuldigen sie sich endlich wegen
dieser nummer und eine frage
interessiert mich auch noch meine lieben
kolleginnen und kollegen ist das
umsetzen ihres acht punkte plans also im
willy brandt haus habe ich gelesen
fairer wahlkampf herr scholz darin heißt
es der bewussten die bewusste
verbreitung mit dem bewussten
verbreitung von falschmeldungen stellen
wir uns entschieden entgegen ich glaube
dass ich empfehle nur im eigenen haus
damit zügig zu beginnen und es gibt
einen skandal keine frage wenn man
nämlich parteitaktisch was ja frau mast
bestreitet erstaunlicherweise okay dann
hat das mit parteitaktik nichts zu tun
obwohl sie selbst mehrfach die spd hier
erwähnt hat wenn man selbst mit
parteitaktischen manövern ängste beim
menschen wird dann macht man wahlkampf
auf dem rücken der schwächeren und ich
glaube das ist eher ein skandal als
alles andere was hier angesprochen wurde
und die spannende frage ist ja
nützt einem das eigentlich
parteipolitisch ist das wirklich
sinnvoll andere schlecht zu machen
ich meine natürlich nicht wer über
andere schlecht redet ist ja selbst noch
längst nicht besser geworden
das wissen die menschen die haben es in
sachsen anhalt überhaupt auch deutlich
gezeigt dass sie das verstanden haben
ich sage nur einstellig in
sachsen-anhalt viel vergnügen mit dieser
strategie für die nächsten wochen
und ja der wahlkampf zieht herauf die
menschen erwarten und haben natürlich
auch ein recht darauf jedenfalls aus
unserer sicht der
cdu/csu-bundestagsfraktion dass diese
koalition bis zum letzten tag der
wahlperiode periode sind seriös arbeitet
wir als cdu csu werden das tun wir
werden weiter mit aller kraft die
pandemie bekämpfen
im übrigen gemeinsam mit einem sehr
erfolgreichen bundesgesundheitsminister
wir werden entschlossen für die
wirtschaftliche erholung unseres landes
kämpfen und sie weiter vorantreiben das
sind nämlich wichtige aufgaben die die
menschen auch wirklich interessieren in
diesem lande dass man nach der pandemie
wieder wirtschaftlich auf die beine
komme kommt nämlich wirtschaftliche
kompetenz ist im übrigen auch die
grundlage für soziale sicherheit da kann
ich auch nur meinem koalitionspartner
sagen vergesst das nie ich will
abschließend sagen gutes regieren bis
zur wahl das ist aus unserer sicht unser
auftrag und gutes regieren nach der wahl
dafür steht cdu/csu auch bereit im
anschluss an die nächste bundestagswahl
der schon in der regierung von der
opposition kommt der wird sich nicht
wundern dürfen wenn er nach der wahl
auch als opposition aufwacht vielen dank
michael grosse brömer eine
parlamentarische geschäftsführer der cdu
csu mit seiner sicht der dinge
der bundestag debattiert in einer
aktuellen stunde über den angeblichen
masten skandal einer auseinandersetzung
zwischen dem arbeitsministerium und dem
bundesgesundheitsministerium und nach
einer stunde debatte 35 hatte ist man
immer noch nicht viel klüger was den
sachverhalt angeht stefan brandner afd
hat jetzt als nächster das wort bei
ihnen der groko und bei ihnen in der cdu
muss die hütte ganz gewaltig brennen
oder wer sich schon erste pdf in so
einer sache die angeblich gar keine
bedeutung hat die hinstellt der erste
pdf der spd kommt noch hinterher
der generalsekretär will sie gleich als
feuerlöscher hier beweisen als dann ist
wahrscheinlich die emotionen richtig
hoch bei ihnen und das ende von ihren
sparen nicht mehr besonders weit denn
schon wieder steht hier in spanien den
schlagzeilen die negativen berichte über
seine person seine leistungen und seine
geschäfte nehmen nicht ab sondern zu und
wenn sie genau hinschauen dann sind die
gegenwärtigen ereignisse eigentlich mehr
der gipfel eines eisbergs oder der
tropfen den eimer zum überlaufen bringt
die spd machte natürlich gerne mit
klammert sich an jeden strohhalm um die
fünf prozent hürde bei der nächsten
bundestagswahl zu überwinden und macht
sich hier zum vorkämpfer der
entrechteten und armen ausgerechnet die
spd ihren gesundheitsexperte lauterbach
der nicht mal im gesundheitsausschuss
sitzt unter heute nicht da ist
ausgerechnet die spd deren
gesundheitsexperte lauterbach vor kurzem
noch empfohlen hat sich
staubsaugerbeutel um den kopf zu wickeln
und corona zu bekämpfen ausgerechnet sie
skandale sind jetzt hier eine angebliche
fehlende zertifizierung von massen
wirklich sehr eigenartig was geht nicht
um die spd da haben wir noch darüber
geredet für diese splitterpartei es geht
um jetzt sparen denken wir mal 15 monate
zurück am anfang der korona krise da sah
es noch ganz gut aus jetzt sparen wurde
in den medien als shooting-star der
krise gefeiert und als souverän agieren
dargestellt dann begab er sich in den
wahlkampf um die spitzenkandidatur und
als cdu-vorsitzender beschäftigte sie
mich sich mit dubiosen
immobiliengeschäften und wurde
mittlerweile dann selbst zur größten
krise wir ihn uns bereits im frühjahr
zahlt sich 20 scheiterte er bei der
beschaffung der masken deshalb wurde
zunächst behaupten überhaupt masken
brächten nicht dass ihren bieren
schleudern hat sogar frau merkel
besagten im zweifel reicht es ein tuch
um den kopf zu wickeln oder ein
staubsauger boere wie es die spd
empfohlen hat als das sparen ministerium
in aufwachte als ersparen
zwischen mehreren notartermin mal etwas
zeit gefunden hat hat er dann planlos
weltweit kreuz und quer irgendwelche
masken geordert die allerdings zu
größten teilen unbrauchbar und maßlos
überteuert waren millionen
milliardenschäden verursacht millionen
euro kosten wahrscheinlich für
angewählte ganz dubiose geschichte
geschichte und geschäfte der kollege
kräuter hatte darauf hingewiesen
von den massen geht profitiert haben
auch und vor allem das gucke ich mal
wieder hier in die reihen der cdu/csu
viel von ihren abgeordneten wobei
interessanterweise bisher erledigt die
hinterbänkler bekannt geworden sind ich
bin mal gespannt was in zukunft noch
herauskommen was sich die vorder winkler
alles so eingesteckt haben ersparen
kümmerte sich um das unternehmen
wir haben schon
nicht weit von seinem wahlkreis vi man
kennt sich sicher auch der ehegatte das
jahr einsparen eine art strippenzieher
des burda konzerns wunder warum ersparen
so gut wie medien davon kommt als
strippenzieher des burda konzerns soll
beteiligt gewesen seien alles in allem
möglicherweise ein finanzierungsmodell
für immobiliengeschäfte der familie
sparen dann der impfstoff sowie nicht
bestellt auch die europäische union
verlassen chaos bei der lieferung keine
konkreten keine verlässlichen
impftermine mal der september war der
juni dann weiß man es nicht genau alles
möglichst noch vor der wahl versprechen
nicht halten hinter der nach der wahl um
an der wahlurne erfolgreich
zusammenarbeiten aus dem römer das wird
nichts geschehen stellte es zentrum
schossen wie pilze aus dem boden jeder
anbieter erhält ohne überprüfung 18 euro
ist wenig getestet ob es wenig geprüft
ob getestet wurde
es wird nicht geprüft wie getestet wurde
jeder kann sich die taschen voll machen
betrüger und krisen profiteure kommen
auf ihre kosten alles zu kosten des
steuerzahlers ersparen und sie bemühen
sich nicht mal die mit rüben auf die
schliche zu kommen und ich bin gespannt
wer sich da bei den altparteien die
taschen voll gemacht hat die masken
hatten wir gerade schnelltests ein
milliardengeschäft da mit der kieler
untersuchungsausschuss in der nächsten
wahlperiode einiges zum vorschein
bringen doch was die impf beschaffung
angeht ist es das gleiche den nächsten
fall ersparen
die korona waren völlig überteuert viel
zu spät kaum genutzt keiner will sie
keiner braucht weiterentwicklung gibt es
nicht peinlich für made in germany das
ist ein beweis dafür welchen
erbärmlichen welchen erbärmlichen
zustand sie und ihre regierung unser
land gewirtschaftet haben nicht
funktioniert hier wir machen uns zum
gespött der welterfolg fröhliche spenden
diener von ersparen wurde noch erwähnt
9.999 euro eintritt ersparen hat
gefeiert mit seinen parteigenossen als
die leute draußen an cholera gestorben
sind und das ist erbärmlich dass sie
abgeleistet haben vor lauter
üblicherweise endet man dann hier mit
einer rücktrittsforderung und sagt so
geht es nicht weiter sparen treten sie
zurück aber ich bin sicher frau merkel
wird sie im amt teil und deshalb von
dieser stelle ersparen
genießen sie die letzten monate im amt
jetzt fragt man sich wie hört man auf
ich hab erst dann mit dem kollegen
martin hohmann gesprochen und er hat
gesagt wir waren
ich empfinde eigentlich nur noch mitleid
mit jetzt sparen und wasser sparen
mir geht es genauso genießen sie die
letzten monate im amt und dann ist auch
feierabend denke ich mal für ihre
parteipolitische geschichte hier in
deutschland vielen dank so war der herr
brandner von der afg an aktuelle stunde
die es in sich hat reinster
wahlkampfleiter von fakten von keiner
seite etwas zu hören am montag gab es
ein bisschen aufklärung das
arbeitsministerium hat da dargestellt
dass das gesundheitsforum november
vorgeschlagen habe die masken verband
ein neues prüfkriterium zu entwickeln
dem habe das arbeitsministerium hat
widersprochen ein sprecher des
gesundheitsministeriums teilte daraufhin
mit
es sei kein neues kriterium entwickelt
worden die frage sei damals gewesen ob
ein bestehendes weiter an gewertet
werden soll angewendet werden soll
carsten schneider noch zu finden aber
das hat brander was sie die eben gemacht
haben und zwar was die es in sumy
insinuieren von möglichen geschäften die
gar nicht profis keinen beweis gebe noch
kein beleg nur ihrer verleumdung des
ehemanns von ein spannendes finde ich
ist ein sauberer
das gehört sich nicht das gehört sich
nicht weiß dass er aller schärfe zurück
sie können sich dem gesundheitsministers
personen auseinandersetzen aber nicht
mit angehörigen wo sie keinerlei belege
für haben ich will zu drei punkten was
sagen erstes zum vorgang der massen
zweitens zur bilanz des
gesundheitsministers und drittens zu
koalitionen herzlich mir kommt ja auch
noch erstes dieser masken fordern die
sozialdemokraten stehen dafür dass haben
doch durchgesetzt das wohl der gruppen
leute die wenig geld haben aber schutz
brauchen obdachlos auch aber inzwischen
jetzt beim empfänger andere den
notwendigen schutzausrüstung bekommen
fdp 28
das haben wir gefordert haben politisch
durchgesetzt es war auch richtig und
diese massen sollen natürlich die
gleichen schutzstandards und
vorkehrungen haben wie alle anderen
anderen verfügung gestellten machen
deswegen hat das arbeitsministerium
sozialministerium klar gesagt dass die
nicht getestet masken die in der jetzt
reserve sich befinden und sollte mal
genutzt werden getestet werden müssen
noch einen standards nicht zum auf den
kopf gestellt
diese entscheidung war richtig und ich
bedanke mich bei lukas heim für diese
klare kante das daraus jetzt eine
aktuelle stunde im politischer vorgang
an sich geworden ist hat ein bisschen
was mit der insgesamt leistungsbilanz
der politische personen ihren sparen zu
tun zudem komme ich ja auf antrag das
hat ja eine ganze reihe von zeit ja auch
witzig genommen das erste ist diese
regierung diese koalition hat diese
corona pandemie aber mit fehlern klar
aber im grunde nachher richtig
ordentlich behandelt und wir kommen sind
in deutschland auch gut damit gefahren
zweitens ersparen hat zu beginn der
pandemie gesagt glaube ich hier im
bundestag in der regierungsbefragung man
müsse sich oder werde sich zeigen dass
das war sehr vorausschauend insbesondere
was das eigene ressort betreffen da habe
ich doch mehr als kritikpunkte sondern
auch wirklich einschlägt andere
entscheidungen anderer einschätzung
erstes die impfstoff beschaffung kam zu
spät zwar auf europäischer ebene zu
gering
sie war teilen zu geizig und wenn
deutschland und ersparen als
gesundheitsminister damals in der
führung in verfügung die die
federführung dafür auch mit hatte so
hätten wir dort schneller und auch
tiefgreifender handeln müssen es hätte
uns ein zwei monate früher mehr
impfstoff beschafft zweitens worüber ich
mich wirklich sehr ärgerlich war die
tests vor ort sehen es geht um
milliarden
wir haben ersparen hat sowas waren mitte
februar angekündigt zum ersten märz
haben alle tests nichts war vorbereitet
was daraus folgte war zum ersten april
mit der konsequenz an viel zu wohnen
durch einen preis von 18 euro und durch
nicht durch fast keine kontrollen eine
einladung zur selbstbedienung dieser
fehler kostet uns sehr viel geld aber
absehbar er war absehbar
haushaltspolitiker und dieser koalition
darauf hingewiesen haben dass es in
weiten teilen eine einladung ist zum
betrug und vor allen dingen auch zu
hoher kosten ist eine politische
verantwortung dass man die sie tragen
und die wir als sozialdemokraten auch
nicht mittragen gegend und zum zweiten
dass gilt angebot für kinder ab zwölf
bekannten stoff da ist enttäuschung die
geschaffen worden die nicht mit klugen
erwartungsmanagement und politik zu tun
haben nun will ich aber ansatz zu
koalition noch sagen die spd hat diese
debatte nicht aufgemacht die spd hat
auch nicht dafür gesorgt dass es dafür
eine wirkliche und gäbe überhaupt muss
weiß ich aber sagen will ist dass diese
sozialdemokratische partei und die
fraktion diese regierung steht
und ich kann nur eins sagen ja große
brömer von kollege zu kollege es ist
eure fraktion die viele beschlüsse die
das kabinett getroffen hat blockiert und
nicht zum abschluss im deutschen
bundestag bringt wenn nicht tage machte
demokratie gesetzt ich nenne
kinderrechte im grundgesetz streichung
des begriffs unternehmen sanktions recht
die hälfte der hälftige aufteilung
der erhöhung des co2 preises für
vermieter all das hat das kabinett eure
bundeskanzlerin bisschen mitbeschlossen
und ihr seid als fraktion nicht bereit
ist hier bundestag mit zu beschließen
das ist so eine entfernung von der
regierungsfähigkeit und letztendlich
auch eine entfremdung zur regierung dass
ich nur sagen kann dass abzuschließen
wir werden im september sehen aber
jahren opposition steht euch auch
gedanken wie weit der parlamentarische
geschäftsführer der spd
bundestagsfraktion carsten schneider
die nächste rednerin hier in der
aktuellen stunde kommt von der
linksfraktion die diese aktuelle stunde
auch beantragt hatte
susanne verstellen sie stellvertretende
fraktionsvorsitzende
[Applaus]
er fährt die kolleginnen und kollegen
ganz offensichtlich haben wir erneut
einen masten skandal milliarden an
steuergeldern werden verbrannt während
gleichzeitig viele menschen dringend
unterstützung bräuchten
verantwortlich dafür ist
gesundheitsminister jens spahn es ist
der jens spahn der vor drei jahren sagte
und ich zitiere hartz iv bedeutet keine
armut damit hat jeder was er zum leben
braucht und andere bezahlen schließlich
über ihre steuern diese leistungen
dieses schräge bild gegenüber armen
menschen und den umgang mit
steuergeldern
das sieht sich jetzt fort aber fangen
wir von vorne an muss ein bisschen
ausholen um den gesamtzusammenhang
darzustellen am anfang der pandemie
waren die masken knapp weil man es
versäumt hatte bestände aufzubauen
obwohl krisenszenarien ganz eindeutig
vorhergesagt haben was passieren könnte
es muss sie ein schnelles
unbürokratisches beschaffungsverfahren
organisiert werden und irgendwann wurde
das ministerium mit aufträgen
überschüttet es gibt lieferanten die
warten noch bis heute auf ihr geld und
das alleine
hat gerichtskosten in millionenhöhe
verursacht auf der anderen seite gab es
lieferanten denen hat man die kohle
hinten und vorne rein gesteckt und für
hohe preise für überteuerte masken
bezahlt wie zum beispiel die schweizer
jungunternehmen von nx die sich jetzt
den ein oder anderen ferrari leisten
können und dieser deal der wurde von
frau und wurde von über ford händler die
tochter des csu-politikers ganz
offensichtlich mit ihnen persönlich ein
geschildert und in der union war es
immer schon so dass man sich
offensichtlich ganz gut kennt und von
dieser goldgräberstimmung da fühlten
sich auch weitere unions kollegen von
sparen wie georg nüßlein und der frühere
bayerische justizminister alfred sauter
angezogen
sie haben mit ihren masken geschäften
mitten in der größten krise ohne skrupel
die eigenen taschen vollgestopft es ist
doch ungeheuerlich meine damen und
herren
was bei all dem auf der strecke blieb
war die qualität der masken durch ein zu
lasches prüfer fand und jetzt ist
öffentlich geworden dass das
gesundheitsministerium hunderte
millionen von masken bestellt hat die
gar keine europäische zulassung haben
eine milliarde euro hat das ministerium
dafür ausgegeben eine milliarde euro für
minderwertige masten und was mich
wirklich anwidert bei hartz iv
empfängerinnen und hartz4 empfängern
generieren sie sich als steuer sparer
aber wenn steuergelder in millionenhöhe
verbrannt werden dann spielt es keine
rolle
es ist wirklich ungeheuerlich aber es
gibt noch weiter
diese masken sollten wir es
offensichtlich verteilt werden an
menschen mit behinderung obdachlose und
grundsicherungsempfänger und
gesundheitsministerium behauptet diese
masken seien auch ohne zertifikat für
die pandemie geeignet aber ich habe
gelernt offensichtlich kann sich hier
das sein eigenes zertifikat basteln um
eines in
aller deutlichkeit zu sagen einen
pandemie schutz erster und zweiter
klasse ist definitiv nicht hinnehmbar
alle menschen haben den gleichen schutz
wie diejenigen die nicht auf der
sonnenseite des lebens stehen trifft die
pandemie sowieso schon viel härter als
wohlhabende während deutschlands
milliardäre in der krise im 100
milliarden euro reicher geworden sind
haben beschäftigte mit mittleren und
niedrigen einkommen massive massive
einkommensverluste und siebenmal
häufiger von arbeitslosigkeit betroffen
aber die bundesregierung hat weder einen
mindest kurzarbeitergeld eingeführt noch
die bezugszeiten vom arbeitslosengeld
verlängert
empfängerin von grundsicherung hatten
mit mehrausgaben und gestiegenen
lebensmittelpreisen zu kämpfen aber es
gab keinen monatlichen pandemie zuschlag
so wie wir ihn gefordert hatten
dauernd wird uns hier erzählt dafür gebe
es kein geld aber hier wird zum
gesundheitsministerium und das rede ich
noch nicht mal vom verkehrsministerium
geld in milliarden-höhe verbraten
das ist doch mit vollen händen zum
fenster rausgeworfen das ist doch
skandalös und ich wüsste jetzt noch
einiges oder könnte noch einiges sagen
aber auch meine redezeit reicht dafür
nicht aus über die verschlafen
impfkampagne die vermasselte corona
waren es über die bereicherung an den
teststationen die verwirrungen um den
digitalen impfnachweis die im fraktion
für kinder und so weiter aber dafür
bräuchte ich tatsächlich eine längere
rede zeit sie haben gesagt herr spahn
man musste sich in der pandemie vieles
verzeihen können aber es geht nicht um
verzeihen
es geht darum verantwortung zu
übernehmen für die politik die unter
ihrer führung gemacht wurde und die
skandale wie sie produziert haben vielen
dank
vielen dank
so jetzt gibt es noch drei redner in der
aktuellen stunde die beiden minister aus
den beiden streitenden ressorts gehören
nicht dazu sondern als nächster für die
cdu/csu rudolf henke er ist mitglied im
ausschuss für gesundheit und
vorsitzender parlamentarisches begleit
gremium cupid und pandemie werde frau
präsidentin liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen meine damen und herren ich habe
ja die aufgabe mich für meine fraktion
im gesundheitsausschuss um das
infektionsschutzgesetz kümmern zu dürfen
und deswegen kenne ich die dortigen
debatten und gesetzgebungsprozesse die
wir als koalition vorgenommen haben
da gibt es jetzt diesen heiß
diskutierten cpi standard da wird so
getan als wäre dieser cpi standard nix
wert hätte keine bedeutung und als
während diejenigen die diesen cpi
standard anwenden welche die
menschenverachtend sind weil sie anderen
zumuten mit masken versehen zu werden
die kein schutzniveau liefern während
andere masken die nach einem anderen
standard geprüft sind ein schutzniveau
gewährleisten das ist ja der kern und
ausgangspunkt dieser debatte und da wird
das mit menschenverachtung garniert ja
kann ja sein dass jemand außerhalb des
parlaments zu einem solchen eindruck
gelangt jedenfalls konnten wir das in
der bild am sonntag lesen
aber die so heiß diskutierte cpi
standard ist in einer anlage zu § 5b
infektionsschutzgesetz abgebildet der
die schutzmaßnahmen schutzmasken für die
nationale reserve gesundheit
schutz bestimmt und auf welches gesetz
geht dieser paragraph zurück auf das
zweite gesetz zur änderung des
infektionsschutzgesetzes und weiter
gesetze und das ist hier in diesem haus
am 20
auf antrag beider koalitionsfraktionen
beschlossen worden und hat am 20
die zustimmung erhalten der fdp und von
bündnis 90 die grünen
da müsste sich mal daran erinnern
erschienen da müssen sie sich daran
erinnern
und ich habe verständnis dafür wenn
parteien die damals das abgelehnt haben
jetzt sagen wir leiten aus unserer
damaligen ablehnung heute kritik ab aber
das protokoll des parlaments ist
eindeutig zu der verabschiedung dieses
gesetzes und in diesem gesetz ging es um
einen änderungsantrag vier der koalition
und da haben wir gemeinsam folgenden
satz beschlossen
die in der nationalen reserve
gesundheitsschutz vorgehaltenen
schutzmasken müssen einen in der anlage
genannten masken typ entsprechen und
auch der maske typ cpi ist dort
aufgeführt zealand deutschland prüft
grundsätze nach bmg farm und schiff vom
bund im rahmen seiner hoheitlichen
aufgaben nach einer verordnung vom 8
april 2020 beschaffte schutzmasken alles
völlig transparent und ich weiß nicht ob
sie hier ist aber ich würde frau
matthias als berichterstatterin zur
zeugin anrufen denn sowohl sie als auch
ich haben im gesundheitsausschuss diesen
änderungsantrag eingebracht und
begründet und vertreten und haben dafür
geworden dass der gesundheitsausschuss
dass uns eine beschlussempfehlung
aufnimmt und ja es gab und gibt zwischen
gesundheitsministerium und
arbeitsministerium offenbar differenzen
aber am ende gar keinen fachlichen
dissenz nach diesem verfahren vorzugehen
und die beratungen zur belieferung von
grün haben gruppen bahn zwischen beiden
ministerien abgestimmt
übrigens auch in der antwort auf ihre
vorhin genannten völklein schweigt
anfrage hat ja die bundesregierung
einvernehmlich geantwortet und hat ja
gesagt dass die durchlass prüfung für
paraffin nicht notwendig ist sondern
dass eine durchaus prüfung für rcl
ausreicht diese position ist ja keine
die das bmg alleine vertreten hätte der
minister
das haben sie im rahmen der
ressortabstimmung gemeinsam so in die
antwort auf die kleine anfrage der
grünen rein geschrieben und deswegen
finde ich muss man sich daran auch jetzt
gebunden halten und deswegen ist der
vorwurf dass dort menschenverachtung am
werkzeug und dass man dort in einer ahs
ist aber ihr parteivorsitzender
verehrter herr minister heil der dort
der welt der bild am sonntag
vorgetragen hat und das will ich dann
doch noch mal in erinnerung rufen wer
als gesundheitsminister menschen in zwei
klassen einteilt nämlich solche mit
anspruch auf qualitätsgeprüfte masken
und die für die absolut untaugliche
masken gut genug sind der ist unwürdig
und menschenverachtend und wenn das
stimmt
dann sind wir abgeordnete und union spd
fdp und bündnis 90 die grünen die den
zugestimmt haben in der gleichen weise
betroffen wie entspannen das finde ich
muss man festhalten bedanke mich für
eure aufmerksamkeit die den dankt rudolf
henke
[Applaus]
die vorletzte rednerin in dieser debatte
kommt von der spd martina stammt wie ich
sie ist patientenbeauftragte der
fraktion und mitglied im ausschuss für
gesundheit
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen sehr geehrte
damen und herren es wäre mir lieber wenn
wir heute nicht schon wieder mit dem
thema schutzmasken uns auseinandersetzen
müssten aber es stehen vorwürfe im raum
die einfach aufgeklärt werden müssen
und lieber ersparen zu beginn der
pandemie haben uns die sinngemäß gesagt
dass wir uns in ein paar monaten
wahrscheinlich gegenseitig viel
verzeichnen müssen
dieser satz gilt für mich nach wie vor
ich mache ihnen deshalb auch keinerlei
vorwürfe bezüglich der chaotischen
beschaffungs phase zu beginn der
pandemie dass in solchen
krisensituationen auch mal war im
einkaufskorb landet die nicht allen
regulären standards erfüllt ist fast
unvermeidlich
auf diese klarstellung lege ich großen
wert heute und hier geht es aber um
etwas anderes
heute geht es darum wie sie und ihr
ministerium mit dieser ware umgegangen
sind und dass wir aktuell wissen dass
die sp hingegen insgesamt dreimal
versucht hat diese nicht regulär
zertifizierten masken auf verschiedene
art und weise und das volk zu bringen
und jedes mal hat das thema es diesen
versuchen widersprochen
interessantes detail ist da dass zu dem
zeitpunkt im herbst 2020 in deutschland
kein mangel an zwei masken herrschte es
ist also eindeutig dass das bmg mehrfach
versucht hat masken die dem ursprünglich
von bmg bmhs und den ländern
erarbeiteten cph prüfstand an gesprächen
unter die leute zu bringen und das
obwohl sich der masken verfügbar war
allein das einschreiten des bhs hat
diesen vorgang letztlich verhindert und
dazu geführt dass konkret zertifizierte
masken ausgegeben wurden
wird sind und seiten des ministers
vorgebracht dass dies alles ja überhaupt
nicht verwerflich sein denken die cpi
zertifizierten masken würden ja aus
infektions technischer sicht
über den c und ce zertifizierten masken
keine nachteile aufweisen
darüber hinaus sei ja auch streng und
engmaschig kontrolliert werden
und genau hier liegt aber die krux diese
behauptung des ministeriums steht auf
wackeligen beinen und wein uns auch
zahlreiche berichte über schritt masken
womit sie die zeichnung erreichen die
bereits ausgeliefert worden sind in
baden-württemberg und in anderen
bundesländern haben nach prüfungen
ergeben dass ein großer teil der vom
bund gelieferten cp maske in puncto
durchlässigkeit weit über den
zugelassenen wir werten liegt daraus
könnte man verschiedene schlüsse ziehen
entweder ist das eigens entwickelte cpb
verfahren vom bmg und seinen partnern
nicht geeignet oder es wurde einfach
nicht korrekt und ausreichend häufig
genug angewendet
in diesem zusammenhang an das bmg dann
auch gleich noch die frage beantworten
weshalb die einschlägigen experten aus
den bereichen unfallversicherung und
produktsicherheit und dazu gehören zls
die dekra und ihr war den vom bmg
ausgearbeiteten cbg prüf grundsatz in
puncto infektionsschutz für unzureichend
halten
vielleicht liegt diese
meinungsverschiedenheit war auch daran
dass ihnen die an der ausarbeitung
beteiligten organisationen und
institutionen unterstehen
wenn das bmg wirklich beweisen will dass
kein fehlverhalten vorliegt dann muss es
jetzt auskunft darüber geben wann wo und
wie und mit welchem ergebnis die
betroffenen masken getestet worden sind
weiter muss aufgeklärt werden ob das bmg
den berichten über mangelhafte cbi
masken lieferungen im vergangenen sommer
entsprechend nachgegangen
ist und ob daraus dann auch konsequenzen
für das testverfahren gezogen worden
sind
ich fasse zusammen wir haben in den
ländern k 95 masken die vom bund
beschafft worden und trotz durchlauf von
eines mehrstufigen prüfverfahren es
offenbar nicht verwendbar sind wir haben
ein ministerium das drei mal versucht
hat schutzmasken die nicht den
konzertierten standards entsprechen und
das volk zu bringen und wir haben ein
ministerium das wichtige details über
die tatsächliche prüfpraxis bei diesen
masken noch nicht herausrückt und eine
nachprüfung der masken bisher verhindert
hat fehler können passieren gerade in
der pandemie aber dieses haus hier hat
jedes recht aufklärung zu verlangen um
wiederholungen zu vermeiden und das sehr
geehrter herr minister sparen ist der
auftrag dieser debatte
vielen dank die gesamte dina stammt ja
meine damen herren und jetzt kommt der
letzte redner hier in der aktuellen
stunde vorher schon ein paar mal
angesprochen paul signac der
generalsekretär der cdu csu
auch er ist bundestagsabgeordneter
insofern kann er natürlich an so einem
tag wie heute auch das wort ergreifen
das tut er jetzt als letzter in der
aktuellen frau präsidentin meine sehr
verehrten damen und herren
als ich kurz vor der landtagswahl in
sachsen anhalt die ersten meldungen über
das thema der heutigen aktuellen stunde
las blieb mir der atem stehen denn die
meldungen waren dass der
bundesgesundheitsminister vorsätzlich
wollte
das stop da strott das schrott masken
sogenannte stop masken die nicht von
corona schützen auch wirklich mehr viele
weise ausgeliefert werden sollen an
hartz 4 empfänger und an behinderte das
fand ich skandalös
ich konnte es nicht glauben und ich
sollte recht bald das
bundesgesundheitsministerium und der
bundesminister selbst haben alles
aufgeklärt in der frage welche masken
wie ausgeliefert und jetzt haben wir
gerade über prüfnormen diskutiert fest
steht heute in der aktuellen stunde
das weder irgendwelche masken an
behinderten einrichtungen an
sozialhilfeempfänger an hartz iv
empfänger ausgeliefert werden sollten es
diesen plan gab oder am ende
ausgeliefert wurden die nicht von corona
schützen das stimmt einfach nicht
und meine sehr verehrten damen und
herren 1
es waren gute masten sie waren geprüft
und der schutz der menschen und der
schutz der vokabel und gruppen statt
immer ganz oben auf der agenda des
bundesgesundheitsministers und des
bundesgesundheitsministeriums
herr scholz 6 doch hier herrscht der
hall bundesminister heil sitzt doch hier
eher kann es ja würde ja widersprechen
wenn das nicht stimmen würde was ich
hier sage deswegen gab es keinen dissens
und wissen sie was was heute schlimm ist
das obwohl diese aufklärung vorliegt
obwohl wir wissen dass diese
behauptungen die als menschenunwürdig
bezeichnet wurden nicht zum anlass
genommen wurden einfach sich zu
entschuldigen zu sagen so war es dann in
wahrheit nicht sondern eine aktuelle
stunde hier nicht nur zu beantragen
sondern darauf zu bestehen obwohl man
weiß wie viele millionen menschen mann
in deutschland versichert indem man das
einfach immer wieder trotz besseren
wissens behaupten meine damen und herren
und dann wurde gesprochen
gerade wurde gesagt warum spricht der
cdu-generalsekretär hier in dieser
debatte
ich kann es ihnen sagen die vorsitzende
der spd die ganze spd führung spricht
von menschenunwürdigen verhalten
plappert in jedes mikrofon dass da
draußen steht aber wenn dieses thema im
plenum des deutschen bundestages
behandelt wird sind sie irgendwo und
gehen irgendwo wieder andere interviews
anstatt hier mal das wort zu ergreifen
was sie eigentlich meinen ich finde es
ist ein zeichen des respekts für dich
als generalsekretär interviews zu dem
thema gehe dass ich hier im plenum stehe
und dazu etwas sagen im gegensatz zur
führung unseres koalitionspartners und
ich muss ihnen gangs ich muss ihn ja ich
muss ihnen ganz offen etwas sagen das
muss ich leider an unseren
koalitionspartner richten ich habe mir
auch noch mal diese selbstverpflichtung
der spd zum fairen wahlkampf angeschaut
das wurde ja auch noch durch die pr
abteilung nach vorne gebracht
da steht dann unter punkt 2 absatz 2
bitte zu haben verlässliche quellen und
fakten sind das fundament unserer
politischen kommunikation
wer überprüft jetzt jetzt noch besser
wir überprüfen behauptungen dritter
bevor wir sie verbreiten jetzt ist die
frage was ist die konsequenz daraus was
heißt das jetzt hier haben jetzt gegen
hier eigene selbstverpflichtung
verstoßen übrigens glaube ich nicht dass
parteien wenn sie ganz normal in der
politischen mitte sind
selbstverpflichtung brauchen für uns wir
brauchen keine selbstverpflichtung firma
wahlkampf ist
für uns eine selbstverständlichkeit ich
kann ihnen nur ja ja was heißt denn das
jetzt sie haben verstoßen
sie behaupten es dort weiter vielleicht
in teilen und keine konsequenz das
papier ist es die wert auf dem es
geschrieben wird ich kann mich meinen
angeboten sie ziehen diese
selbstverpflichtung funktioniert ja bei
ihnen offensichtlich nicht ich kann
ihnen ich bin vater zweier kinder es
gibt ein wunderbares buch schreibe
flunkert heißt ja heißt das buch es ist
wie der verlags ankündigt das ist aber
die nur für die spd sondern für alle
anderen die heute falsches behauptet
haben der verlag sagt nett und liebevoll
werden die charaktere gezeichnet sicher
ein gutes buch um mit kindern über das
thema schwindeln lügen übertreiben und
wie schlecht es ist andere schlecht zu
machen zu diskutieren das sollten sie
mal verteilen meine damen und herren es
ist wie so häufig in der geschichte
unseres landes falschbehauptungen leider
die grünen sind wieder mit sich selbst
beschäftigt vor dem parteitag alles
geschenkt haben jetzt keine zeit fürs
land vielleicht streifen sie das land
sogar aus dem titel
und am ende geht es darum wer übernimmt
verantwortung wie wir aus dieser krise
kommen nach dem sommer wie wir unsere
wirtschaftliche stabilität bewahren und
wie wir vernünftig auf den boden
schlicht von tatsachen diesem land
dienen und dafür steht die cdu/csu bei
dieser bundestagswahl und ich mache ich
noch ein
der regisseur des un generalsekretärs
die bundesregierung soll arbeiten für
das land die parteizentrale machen
wahlkampf nicht anderswo manchmal kann
man manche ministerien der spd mit dem
willy-brandt-haus leider nicht mehr
verwechselt danke polzin jörg war das
generalsekretär der cdu in einer
aktuellen stunde die auf antrag der
linksfraktion stattgefunden hat und in
der es um presseberichten über
möglicherweise minderwertige
schutzmasken gegangen ist so richtig
viel schlauer ehrlich gesagt bin ich
jetzt nicht so geworden beim verfolgen
dieser debatte der schwarze peter ist
weiter fröhlich hin und hergeschoben
worden die vorwürfe auch so dass wir
insgeheim hoffen vielleicht in
absehbarer zeit doch noch mal eine
objektive erkenntnis zu diesem ganzen
vorgang zu bekommen